how terrified is Joe Biden of the
radicals in his party well here's one
measure he's so terrified that he just
made Alexandria Kazuya Cortes the head
of his global warming task force she's
the woman who blames hurricane deaths on
racism do we see largely that it's the
global South and communities of color
that may be bearing the brunt of the
initial havoc from climate change
without a doubt without a doubt and in
terms of that wealth the people who are
producing climate change the folks that
are responsible for the largest amount
of emissions or communities or
corporations they tend to be
predominantly white correct yes and
every study backs that up so not really
a science person that Acacio Cortez now
she's running global warming for Joe
Biden what is going on here Dana Perino
has been watching she hosts the daily
briefing of course with Dana Perino
always delighted to have her so my
theory Dana and knock it down if you
like is that Biden isn't wedded to deep
beliefs and he is at this point a vessel
for the some of them were radical people
in his party I think that's right well
it certainly gives that appearance right
so if you if you show me a candidate
that is still worried about their base
at this point in the general election
I'll show you somebody who is very
unsteady as a candidate I can't tell you
how happy Republicans were yesterday
Tucker when they found out that AOC is
going to be in charge of energy policy
and climate policy for the Biden
campaign because Biden is actually
courting voters that already were going
to vote for him right but he's turning
off the voters who may have voted for
him so for example aoc turns off people
in the suburbs like in the district at
the Republicans flipped last night in
California how about the people in
Pennsylvania who rely on fracking jobs
they've said that they want to kill that
through the green New Deal and you know
the justice Dems she's a part of they
lost that seat last night they lost in
Wisconsin Ileana O'Mara's has a really
tough race nobody is actually listening
to the AOC s and the omar's in the party
because they're dwindling in power but
Joe Biden keeps giving them new life
it's kind of bath length
it's not baffling once you understand
what you just said which is this is what
weak candidates do they pander to the
fringes because they haven't shored them
up right and so I think that if you have
something like you in Pennsylvania
that's gonna be a that's gonna be a
battleground there's no doubt about that
you already have people in a tough spot
when it comes to unemployment in this
because of the pandemic but the the
energy jobs are in particular danger of
maybe not even coming back if they can't
get back quickly and if they think that
Joe Biden is going to bring on aoc as
the climate adviser will they like game
over I think that president Trump would
play at least be able to win those
voters quite handily in Pennsylvania
that's such a smart point and as you
noted he doesn't really need to do this
but he's doing it anyway which tells you
something pretty weird
no it's hurting him I mean he was able
to actually win this nomination by
knocking them down and now he's
embracing them it doesn't make sense
it's very strange but I think he's a
vessel for others and that's that's
maybe the worst thing Dana great to see
you tonight thank you so much for that
good to see you
have a good night